aussi grave aussi critiquable aussi
inqualifiable aussi impardonnable que
celle dont nous avons tous été à notre
corps défendant les témoins il y a
quelques mois
car enfin mes chers collègues comment
pouvez vous imaginer qu'un nouveau
jérôme cahuzac avec le texte que vous
voulez nous faire adopter rendrait enfin
public des dépôts monétaires à
l'étranger qu'ils auraient constitué sur
la base d'une fraude fiscale je ne vous
crois pas si naïf que de croire que vous
allez réellement répondre à cette
difficulté par ce type de texte
car en réalité vous n'y répondrai pas
c'est une première raison de vous dire
que nous ne sommes pas dupe des
intentions politiques qui sont à peine
cachée derrière les motifs de votre
projet la deuxième chose que je veux
vous dire ce sont les conditions
d'élaboration de ce texte
je déplore que vous n'ayez à aucun
moment rechercher par une discussion
pluraliste comme celle qui avait eu lieu
il ya quelques années autour de notre
présidente de l'époque de la commission
des lois des solutions équilibrées au
problème de la déontologie de la vie
publique de la transparence de la vie
publique
et d'ailleurs quand vous vous êtes mêlée
de réunir une commission à ce sujet elle
n'a à aucun moment consulter les élus
souvenez-vous de la commission présidée
par monsieur jospin il ya quelques mois
et qui d'ailleurs avait oublié de
traiter dans le détail les questions
dont nous sommes aujourd'hui saisi le
troisième point sur lequel je veux
insister après avoir souligné vraiment
les défauts de des conditions de départ
de l'introduction de ce texte les
défauts de l'élaboration unilatérale par
le gouvernement et son administration de
ce texte il ya le fait que le point de
déséquilibre sur lequel vous vous êtes
arrêté n'est pas acceptable la publicité
des déclarations ne sert à rien sinon à
faire plaisir à quelques organisations
politicienne qu'ils s'arrangeront pour
faire des campagnes extrémistes sur les
revenus des élus elle ne sert à rien ce
qui est important ce sont les pouvoirs
de l'instance qui contrôlent
l'enrichissement entre déclare deux
déclarations de patrimoine
meron publiques des déclarations y
compris
clarations mensongère ça ne sert à rien
les français ne seront pas du faux c'est
pourquoi je reprends à mon compte
l'excellente expression de tartufferie
qui a été utilisé plus tôt dans notre
débat quant aux tiers j'appelle tiers
des personnes auxquelles les lui est
attaché parce qu'aujourd'hui les liens
ne sont pas tous des liens qui ont reçu
une formule juridique
j'appelle tiers les enfants j'appelle
tiers les parents comment voulez-vous
que un élu puisse obtenir de ses tiers
des informations que ceux ci ne sont
nullement obligé de par la loi de donner
à quiconque et pensez vous que dans
toutes les familles de france les
enfants connaissent le patrimoine des
parents les parents connaissent le
patrimoine des enfants on connaisse le
patrimoine des des personnes auxquelles
on est lié absolument pas et c'est une
liberté que tout citoyen
alors s'il est absolument nécessaire
d'être intrusif dans la vie des familles
des élus qui ne sont pas pour grand
chose dans l'engagement public autrement
que par le soutien qu'ils apportent à
ces élus qui ne sont pas pour grand
chose dans cet engagement public en tout
cas je ne vois pas pourquoi on expose
les familles de la manière dont vous le
faites et les personnes liées aux élus
et je crois que c'est une grande
frustration de droits individuels qui
sont reconnues depuis plusieurs
décennies depuis 200 ans au français de
toutes conditions
enfin en ce qui concerne les intérêts
mais alors là c'est la porte ouverte à
toutes les mises en cause nos intérêts
sont multiples et en général nos
intérêts sont légitimes qui appartient à
une confrérie philosophique c'est un
intérêt qui s'est engagé dans le
mouvement associatif c'est un intérêt
qui a eu une profession dans les années
passées tout à fait honorable c'est un
intérêt ou allez vous vous arrêtez à
partir du moment où vous ne fixé aucune
limite dans la définition des intérêts
préférant vous reposer sur l'idée que
l'élu lui-même se fait des intérêts
qu'il conviendrait de déclarer donc sur
sa bonne foi mais comment voulez-vous
fonder un compte
rôle sur la bonne foi il ya là une
contradiction intellectuelle qui me
paraît inassumable enfin il ya un point
que je crois être le plus grave de tous
dans le franchissement des lignes jaunes
c'est le système de ce que vous avez
qualifié élégamment de lanceurs d'alert
et qu'on pourrait aussi bien requalifier
de délation de dénonciation moi je ne
veux pas de la république des délateurs
je considère que oui il faut protéger
des français qui de bonne foi donne à la
commission à la l'instance chargée de
contrôler les choses
des informations qui sont prouvées mais
ceux qui vont lancer sur la place
publique des calomnies qui seront
irréparable car on enverra l'inanité
qu'au bout de un ou deux ans eh bien ces
personnes-là ces délateurs ces
dénonciateurs notre république ne doit
pas les inviter à s'épanouir en place
publique alors mes chers collègues
ça fait tout de même beaucoup de raisons
mais il y en a encore une sur laquelle
je veux revenir en un instant le
discrédit de la parole publique
il vient du fait qu'on prend des
engagements et qu'on fait le contraire
après personne n'a obligé votre candidat
françois hollande à dire qu'ils
renégocierait le traité budgétaire avant
de le faire adopter sans en changer une
virgule
personne n'a obligé votre candidat
françois hollande à dire qu'il fallait
remettre en cause la réforme des
retraites alors qu'il veut aujourd'hui
la grave et personne n'a obligé votre
candidat françois hollande à dire qu'il
allait résoudre le problème des
oubliettes d'aulnay où de florange
personne n'a oublié non plus la promesse
de votre président françois hollande de
ne pas augmenter les impôts en 2014
alors que son ministre monsieur
moscovici vient d'annoncer cette hausse
d'impôts dans le prochain budget
personne ne vous a obligé à supprimer la
tva anti délocalisation pour ensuite la
rétablir sous une autre forme
alors mes chers collègues je me doutais
que j'allais un peu vous agacer je
regrette presque d'y avoir mis 1
trop de véhémence mais croyez bien je le
fais avec sincérité je crois que si nous
voulons réhabiliter la parole publique
dans notre pays il faut commencer par ne
pas prendre d'engagement conseil ne pas
pouvoir tenir et par tenir les
engagements qu'on a pris part dont de
cette morale élémentaire mais si nous
parvenions les uns et les autres à nous
en tenir à cela un grand pas en avant
serait fait pour le moment je veux vous
dire que vraiment vraiment nous
aimerions pouvoir voter ce texte vous
n'avez pas fait le nécessaire pour que
nous puissions le faire je le déplore
et pour nous donner une dernière chance
de l'obtenir
je vous demande et je le demande
particulièrement à vous qui n'est pas
spécialement bien disposés par rapport à
cette question préalable
je vous demande s'il vous plaît dans un
instant de raisons d'adopter cette
question préalable mais disponibles pour
travailler avec vous merci mon cher
collègue je passe la parole à monsieur
alain anziani orateurs contre la motion
oui monsieur le président de ce ministre
mes chers collègues et rassurez vous je
ne peux pas vous répéter ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais un certain nombre
d'éléments pourtant pour être utile je
voudrais commencer par saluer monsieur
philippe bas il s'est dit heureux c'est
déjà bien heureux de défendre cette
question préalable je ne suis pas moins
heureux de la combat il s'est dit
heureux de défendre cette question cas
là mais si vous me permettez chaque
collègue vous êtes un peu trompé de
motion où j'ai l'impression vous avez
commencé par nous expliquer qu' il
fallait faire un renvoi en commission et
non la question préalable n'est pas un
renvoi en commission et flamands
monsieur pierre yves collombat ilahiri
usurpé votre fonction vous prendre votre
votre euros alors vous allez commencer
par par cette confusion
vous avez terminé par une autre
confusion qui est le réquisitoire
vous avez terminé par ex histoire
purement politicien
purement politicien et donc vous êtes
trompé deux fois dans votre propos et
vous êtes même tromper une troisième
fois puisque 1 longueur de propos vous
avez dit mais finalement quel dommage
que nous ne revenions pas en commission
et que là nous n'excluons pas le rapport
de monsieur y est avec cliff combat avec
quelques autres avec quelqu'un de
l'ensemble des groupes avec moi même
eh bien nous avons effectivement rédigé
ce rapport mais est ce que vous l'avez
lu quand vous dites dans ce rapport vous
dit tout le bien de ce rapport mais
ensuite après vous nous dites que au
fond il faut pas de déclaration
d'intérêts ou pas de cette façon la
proposition numéro 4 du rapport y est
qui n'est pas là je le regrette il faut
une déclaration d'intérêts qu'ils soient
imposées à l'ensemble des parlementaires
quand vous nous dites vous mêler de la
vie privée et des rémunérations annexes
proposition 12 du rapport
il faut une déclaration des
rémunérations alex proposition 13
on allait même plus loin il faut que la
déclaration d'intérêt fixe évaluent
l'ensemble des rémunérations trois ans
avant le début de mandat et là vous vous
dites tout à l'heure à un sommet de nous
faire une bo dégagements sur les proches
qui ne doivent pas être concerné mais
alors vous êtes en pleine contradiction
avec monsieur y est puisque la
proposition 14-10 à qu'il fallait
intégrer les intérêts des proches il
faut choisir monsieur bah il faut
choisir entre rapport de yes et puis vos
propres propos je serais trop long mais
je dis si vous voulez rapport y est voté
le projet doit vidalis parce que vous
allez retrouver beaucoup de propositions
interdire les fonctions de conseil par
exemple c'était nos rapports y est c'est
dans le projet de loi que propose le
gouvernement
vous dites dans le rapport y est il faut
interdire la compatibilité entre la
fonction parlementaire et la présence
d'un syndicat professionnel c sera dans
la loi puisque à la commission nous
avons voté l'amendement
hier matin ou au bout la semaine
dernière vous dites il faut toujours à
paris s mais leur apport ya justement
nous précise qu'il faut éviter le cumul
entre la fonction commentaires une
fonction de direction dans une
entreprise c'est dans le rapport que
dans le projet de loi que propose le
gouvernement
et après et après il ya quelque chose
qui redoute vous faire frémir
vous savez ce qu'il ya dans le rapport y
est on le connaît bien avec perrine dans
le rapport y est il y a
cette proposition quand même quitté un
peu provocante
n'est ce pas qui consiste à dire qu'un
parlementaire pourraient continuer à
cumuler sa fonction de parlementaire et
une activité professionnelle mais que sa
rémunération serait limitée à la moitié
la rémunération à titre d'avocat à titre
de dentiste à titre de notaire at il de
ce que vous voulez serait limitée à la
moitié de l'indemnité parlementaire
si dans le rapport y est est ce que vous
voulez qu'on le mette dans le projet de
loi
j'attends votre amendement monsieur bah
alors on voit on voit en fait donc je
vais sans doute trompé un peu de deux
motions et j'ajouterais que la question
préalable c'est quoi la question
préalable c'est une définition précise
il n'y a pas lieu à poursuivre la
délibération ses salades efficio la
proie
il n'y a pas lieu ça veut dire quoi au
fond n'y a rien à voir je reprends mon
expression tout à l'heure circulez il
n'ya rien à voir
alors j'ai eu la curiosité d'aller
regarder quand même ce document que nous
recevons tout ce qui est le bulletin
quotidien
j'ai regardé le bulletin quotidien
d'hier pour vraiment voir s'il n'y avait
rien à voir je regarde page 3 du
bulletin quotidien
affaire bettencourt abus de faiblesse
trafic d'influencé
page 3 du même bulletin quotidien
affaire karachi passe 17 du multaq bien
l'ancien ministre pierre bédier s'est
amusé de quel gouvernement ça
et bien l'ancien ministre pierre bédier
qui a été condamné effectivement parce
qu'il avait traficoter quelques marchés
publics
il vient d'être élu effectivement mais
en tout cas vous voyez bien que les
problèmes ne datent pas de ces dernières
années et puis vous avez même page 24 du
bulletin quotidien
l'ancien ministre du tourisme léon
bertrand il appartenait à quel
gouvernement lui est bien lui aussi
il vient d'être condamné à trois ans de
prison ferme dans une affaire
d'attribution illégale de marchés
publics en guyane
et puis évidemment je ne peux pas le
passer sous silence vous avez tout à
fait au début je reviens à la page 5
l'ancien présent la république nicolas
sarkozy dénonce avec virulence la
décision du conseil constitutionnel de
rejeter les comptes de campagne alors
quoi à mes collègues
enfin est-ce que quand même si nous
remettons en question les institutions
et la plus haute institution quel
conseil constitutionnel au motif qu'elle
ne fait qu'appliquer les textes les
textes que vous même vous allez voter
les textes eux pendant cinq ans vous
n'avez pas réformer alors vous admettez
aujourd'hui qu'on critique ces textes et
finalement que vous avez voté que vous
n'avez pas réformé et qu'on fait un an
qu'on critique
le conseil constitutionnel je trouve que
tout ça est bien exagéré et vous feriez
mieux sans doute d'avoir plus de mesure
je terminerai en précisant au fond à
quoi vous posez vous vous opposez si
bonne question
et bien moi j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
que vous allez vous opposez pour
voyeurisme et bien il n'en est pas
question ici
relisez le projet de loi du gouvernement
jamais vous ne trouvez évidemment la
moindre allusion à une volonté de
franchir les limites d'essayer de
regarder ce qui est caché
jamais jamais ici il est simplement
question effectivement que chacun assume
ce qu'il est et ce qu'il fait et ça doit
pas nous gêner d'assumer ce que nous
sommes et ce que nous faisons c'est même
sans doute le principe élémentaire de
l'éthique en politique vous opposer à
quoi au contrôle
quelqu'un m'a fait observer et je
reprends le propose c'est pas ça ne sont
pas moi donc j'aime bien ce juillet ça
choque c'est assez juste
quand même pendant combien pendant
plusieurs années vous nous avez servi
assez fréquemment
l'idée qu'il faut mettre des radins à
tous les coins de feu et quand nous
mêmes nous opposions en disant mais
finalement pas les radars mais les
caméras vidéo quand nous mais nous
disions mais quand même peut-être que
six caméras vidéo à tous les coins soit
il faudra être modérée vous aviez une
réplique qui était parfaite qui était
définitive les honnêtes gens n'ont pas
peur d'être filmé et bien moi je vous
retourne ça les zones elles
parlementaires n'ont pas peur de la
constance moi je crois que vous vous
opposez mais vous aurez peut-être pas
compte a une espérance de probabilité
qui existent profonde dans ce pays
cette espérance de probité civrac elle
ne concerne pas que la politique
elle concerne les médias elle concerne
le monde des banques
elle concerne le monde des affaires dans
son ensemble bien une profonde espérance
de probité
elle ne concerne pas d'ailleurs que la
france elle concerne l'ensemble des
démocraties et en particulier les
démocraties en crise regardez vous
verrez que dans la plupart des pays
aujourd'hui la question de la
transparence redevient évidemment une
question d'actualité
alors j'ai envie de vous dire presque en
vous invitant avec sympathie
ne restez pas dans le dernier quart y
est
arrêt ne restez pas dans le dernier
carré de ceux qui ne veulent ni voir ni
entendre
ne restez pas comme si le monde autour
nous ne bougeait pas et comme uniquement
face à les événements qui se multiplient
j'en ai cité quelques-uns cet après-midi
en début d'après-midi en avez cité
d'autres dont la sphère du médiator ne
restez pas avec ça que dans cette phrase
à la bouche qui consistait à dire cela
ne concerne pas je ne suis pas concernée
je ne suis pas concernée je ne suis pas
concerné ce n'est pas une réponse
il est vrai que 95% d'entre nous ne
sommes pas concernés par toutes ces
affaires il reste 5 % et à cause de 5%
nous avons la responsabilité collective
justement d'aller plus loin de rendre
plus transparent dette exigeant nous
avons la responsabilité collective
d'être exemplaires et de le montrer
merci merci mon cher collègue
je vais demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président en sueur vous avez
la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'écoutais beaucoup de soin monsieur bah
je voulais juste un bon taux l'hiver de
robin premièrement lorsque vous avez dit
nous voudrions voter ce texte où nous
aimerions voter ce texte
chez j'ai pensé à eux pardonnez moi à
cette pièce de molière qui fut déjà cité
oui ça c'est la première marque et la
deuxième la deuxièm e pour vous rappeler
ce qu'a voté la commission mots chers
collègues parce que vous nous avez fait
tout un développement sûr que le conflit
d'intérêts en disant voilà c'est
inadmissible qu'est ce que on va nous
demander les associations qu'elles nous
participons les clubs philosophique
je vous cite un certain nombre
d'institutions d'associations bénévoles
et alors c'est scandaleux et c'est oui
d'accord
viens je pense que vous étiez en
commission ce matin vous étiez là et il
ne vous a pas échappé que la commission
a décidé d'adopter un amendement
cet amendement il supprime pour les
déclarations d'intérêts la ligne à
numéro 34 de l'article 1 de la loi
organique la ligne numéro 34
je le lis huitièmement dans les
déclarations les autres liens
susceptibles de faire naître un conflit
d'intérêt et pourquoi avons-nous adopté
cet amendement pour que justement il n'y
ait aucune suspicion mais une totale
clarté les conflits d'intérêts sont
clairement définis et nous nous sommes
dit à d'ailleurs ça a été une réaction
assez majoritaire et même largement
majoritaires
lorsque l'on marque les autres liens
susceptibles de faire naître un conflit
d'intérêt cela ne peut en voir renvoyer
à toute une série d'engagements ou de
participation qui ne sont pas définies
donc il n'est pas bien que ce soit dans
la loi donc nous l'avons supprimés et
donc vous pouvez vous avez satisfaction
à cet égard et ne vous a pas échappé non
plus que cet amendement qui est adopté
par la commission a pour signataires
avez-vous bien suivi à pour signataires
jean jacques hyest
et c'est pour ça vous souvenez tout d'un
coup vous l'avez voter et comme vous
l'avez voter vous vous souvenez que vous
avez eu tort de dire tout ce que vous
avez raconté tout à l'heure on est bien
d'accord donc je vous remercie
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le président à vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président je pense que
après la les observations d'alain
anziani et la démonstration du
rapporteur
le gouvernement ne va pas en rajouter
car personne n'a véritablement pu
comprendre vous vouliez revenir le
départ de votre explication était
effectivement interrogatif plutôt de
nature je dirais il faut poursuivre le
travail mais la fin je pense que la fin
éclairer le départ l'objectif c'était
voilà de revenir à ce que je pensais
avoir évacué
évidemment c'est la liberté du débat
parlementaire si vous souhaitez obtenir
un discours de niveau politique
politiciens même permettez-moi de le
dire parce que c'est comme ça que je les
ressentis dans tous les cas c'est votre
liberté dans tous les cas ça n'éclairait
pas me semble-t-il la démarche d'un
rejet préalable et pour les raisons qui
ont été exposées précédemment le
gouvernement émet un avis défavorable si
mon cher à monsieur le ministre
pardon je vais consulter le sénat sur la
question préalable y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
le règlement stipule qu'il peut y avoir
une part groupe monsieur longuet vous
avez la parole oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je voudrais naturellement
défendre la motion préalable présentée
par avec talent par mon collègue
philippe bas je crois qu'il n'ya
simplement aucun malentendu
philippe bas a défendu le travail de
notre haute assemblée travail collectif
travail consensuel qui s'est traduit par
le rapport 518 veut-il dire pour autant
qu'ils adoptent et qu'il accepte et que
le groupe ump a dope et accepte toutes
les dispositions du rapport 518 la
réponse est naturellement non mais ce
qui est ce qui nous différencie monsieur
le ministre de l'action gouvernementale
c'est qu'il s'agit d'un travail qui
vient du sénat qui vient de
parlementaires expérimentés chambre
n'est attaché à l'image de la haute
assemblée et qui accepte en effet des
sacrifices sur leur confort quotidien
pour consolider l'image de cette
institution
si vous aviez utilisé pour ce projet
déposé trop rapidement et assez
largement contradictoires si vous aviez
accepté les méthodes qui ont été celles
du président y est
plusieurs mois de travail de réflexion
et d'approfondissement nous aurions pu
peut-être marquer des différences
constatées des oppositions et il y en a
d'ailleurs au sein de l'opposition
il y en a à l'intérieur du groupe de
l'ump il y en a certainement d'ailleurs
également chez vous dans la majorité au
sein du groupe socialiste mais au moins
nous aurions le le sentiment d'aller au
fond de chacune des questions et
d'ailleurs le président sueur me donne
l'occasion à travers ce petit incident
du paragraphe 32 de l'article 20 ils
n'ont pas 34
c'est le sens 36-6 tiré huit le 8e temps
du sang 36-16 c'est c'est complètement
c'est exactement ce que je visais dans
l'inconstitutionnalité je n'ai pas la
compétence et la qualité pour donner un
cours de droit j'y reviendrai dans les
riques dans les textes que nous
présenterons au conseil constitutionnel
dans le dispositif le plus le plus serré
de notre proposition mais il y avait
justement cette cette référence paraphe
tout autre intérêt et vous avez eu
l'intelligence parce que vous ne manquez
pas monsieur le président de la
commission des lois de retirer cet
amendement avec le soutien de jean
jacques hyest parce que manifestement
c'était trop facile pour nous d'obtenir
la censure par le conseil
constitutionnel de ce dispositif
mais je vous rassure au regard des
textes fondamentaux que j'ai évoqués et
sur lesquelles je reviendrai de
l'article 2 l'article iv de l'article 6
de l'article 16 de la ddh et en
particulier en revenant sur les
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
celle notamment du du 30 avril 2000
où a été censuré un texte interdisant
l'accès aux fonctions de parlementaire
de l'élu consulaire
vous verrez bien que nous avons les
bases et ses bases pourquoi les moque
des bases d'attac et ses bases existent
parce que vous avez bâcler ce sujet
majeur dans la précipitation qui était
la vôtre pour des raisons d'opportunité
politique c'est la raison c'est un motif
supplémentaire pour soutenir philippe
pas parce que s'il termine sur un ton
politique ce qui n'est pas parce que ce
projet de loi organique et ce projet de
loi n'ont qu'un ressort politique de
circonstance alors que le sujet méritait
d'aller sur le fond je terminerai par
une conviction personnelle que vous
n'avez pas l'air de comprendre monsieur
le ministre je suis attaché à la vie
parlementaire
on peut appartenir à l'ump sans être par
exemple un présidentialiste de stricte
obédience
je pense en particulier christian du
président de la république au suffrage
universel n'est pas certainement la
meilleure solution est que le
quinquennat est une tragédie par rapport
au septennat
j'appartiens une formation qui me donne
le droit de penser cela c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle j'ai soutenu
edouard balladur qui avait les mêmes
convictions cela peut parfois m'ont posé
ou me distancier de charles pasqua qui a
présenté à la fois le texte de 88 et
celui de 95 et qui était pourtant
parlementaires et sénateurs chevronnés
moins attaché à l'autonomie du sénat
quand il était au gouvernement que
lorsqu'il était à la serbie et bien moi
je suis attaché l'autonomie du sénat
quand je siège au sénat et comme et
lorsque il m'arrive parfois par hasard
de siéger au gouvernement et dont je
pense que cette commission qui est être
greffière dans la loi 88 qui a en 25 ans
acquis une certaine expérience n'a
cependant pas vocation à être une haute
autorité sans méconnaître gravement le
principe de la séparation des pouvoirs
merci mon cher collègue je cède la
parole à monsieur favier doit
explications de vote
sur président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je voulais d'abord me
permets de vous faire part de notre
étonnement à la lecture de la question
préalable qui nous est soumise selon
laquelle ce projet de loi n'aurait pas
lui être discuté
ceux là même qui n'étaient pas avares il
ya quelques temps d'indignation
lorsqu'il s'agissait de fustiger le
comportement de l'ancien ministre du
budget nous propose donc aujourd'hui
d'abandonner tout débat visant à
assainir le fonctionnement de notre
république
je ne sais pas s'il s'agit évidemment
d'un embarras récent du fait de l'état
l'âge dans la presse des arrangements
par exemple que bernard tapie a pu
passer avec l'ancienne majorité
mais dans tous les cas on voit bien ici
dans cette assemblée le conservatisme a
décidément la vie dure
bien entendu la multiplication récente
des affaires de collusion entre le
pouvoir politique et le milieu des
affaires nous montre bien qu'il n'en est
rien les conflits d'intérêts
symptomatique d'une république malade de
la personnalisation du pouvoir et du néo
libéralisme économique se font de plus
en plus visible il en va de notre
responsabilité donc d'ouvrir un débat
sur cette question afin de redresser
donc l'image désastreuse que les
français ont malheureusement aujourd'hui
de leurs élus c'est par cette discussion
que nous arriverons à nous assurer de la
probité de tous de tous les
représentants du peuple et je regrette à
ce sujet que le gouvernement est encore
une fois engagé la procédure accélérée
pour la discussion de ce texte
combien même ils gagneraient donc être
discuté en profondeur
il apparaît clairement que le texte qui
nous est proposé s'il va dans le bon
sens n'est pas encore totalement à la
hauteur des enjeux qui nous concerne il
faudra en particulier veiller à ce que
l'adoption de ce texte ne savent pas au
gouvernement pour se défausser d'une
politique ambitieuse de lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale l'ugtt qui à
nos yeux nous paraît tout aussi
importantes que celles pour la
transparence et c'est bien pour cela mes
chers collègues que je vous appelle à
rejeter donc cette question préalable
il est indispensable que nous puissions
nous saisir de cette discussion pour
ensemble encore améliorer ce texte et
des perspectives d'amélioration sont
nombreuses
si nous voulons pas faire de cette haute
autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique une
nouvelle inutile commission pour la
transparence financière de la vie
politique
soyons donc ambitieux renforçons la
définition du conflit d'intérêts dans la
loi pour lui donner une réelle force
juridique
soyons au disque audacieux de nom à
cette autorité un réel pouvoir d'
enquête afin qu'elles puissent mener à
bien ses missions
n'ayant pas peur d'assumer l'existence
potentielle de conflits d'intérêts chez
des ministres des parlementaires
concernant certains sujets et imposons
donc une obligation de déport pour les
membres du gouvernement pour les
présidents de commissions et pour les
rapporteurs dans les cas litigieux
n'hésitons pas ouvrir une vraie
réflexion sur les incompatibilités entre
mandat parlementaire et activité
professionnelle pour que plus jamais un
élu ne se serve de son mandat pour
s'enrichir de quoi donc avez vous donc
si peur pour refuser ainsi ce débat
pourquoi devenez vous aussi fébrile
lorsqu'on parle de probité de prévention
des conflits d'intérêts ou de respect de
l'intérêt général
à la vue du malaise que ce texte donc
peut causer chez certains je suis
d'autant plus assurée du caractère
indispensable donc de cette discussion
je voulais déjà exprimé je ne partage
pas effectivement entièrement la vision
de la transparence et des conflits
d'intérêts inscrits dans ce texte mais
je suis intimement convaincu que notre
république
à défaut d'une réflexion
institutionnelle globale a besoin d'une
réforme en ce sens et donc dans ce sens
nous voterons donc contre cette question
préalable
je consulte le sénat sur la question
préalable opposé par monsieur jean
claude gaudin et les membres du groupe
ump et dans l'adoption aurait pour effet
d'entraîner le rejet du texte en
discussion
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos j'invite les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 196 sur la
motion temps reposer la question
préalable nombre de votants 343 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 340 2 pour
l'adoption 166 contre 176
le sénat n'a pas adopté la motion tend à
opposer la question préalable
on continue l'opow monsieur pierre yves
collombat et plusieurs de ses collègues
ont déposé une motion qu'on a on renvoie
à la commission du texte en discussion
cette motion porte le numéro 105
rectifier la parole est à monsieur
pierre yves collombat orateurs pour la
motion
oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la femme de césar ne saurait être
soupçonnable ainsi ainsi le futur maître
de rome justifiait il ya bien longtemps
à la fois la répudiation de sa seconde
épouse est ce qu'on oublie généralement
l'absolution de son séducteur les uns
prétendent que césar par la com il
pensait commente plutarque
d'autres croient qu'ils cherchaient à
plaire au peuple qui voulait sauver
l'accusé afin d' un côté de ne pas
s'attirer par sa condamnation le
ressentiment du peuple et de l'autre
pour ne pas se déshonorer aux yeux des
bons citoyens par une absolution
formelle sous la république consulaires
qui est la nôtre que le titulaire du
pouvoir suprême commettent une erreur de
casting trop voyante dans le choix d'un
de ses ministres
et c'est l'ensemble des élus nationaux
une bonne partie des élus locaux et des
acteurs de la vie publique qui sont
sommés comme la femme de césar de rendre
des comptes
non pas seulement de ce qu'ils font mais
de la manière dans les autres le
perçoivent
et pour que les lavertue leurs vertus ne
faiblissent pas les voici placé sous la
surveillance des électeurs des réseaux
de formatage de l'opinion en charge du
pilori symbolique sauver les apparences
en détournant l'attention des coupables
fonctionner sur des fonds est coupable
fonctionnelle sans effleurer ce qui
fâche fait partie de l'arsenal de
gouvernement particulièrement par temps
de crise la crise dure en
s'approfondissant faute de remède adapté
cette accélération de l'histoire n'a
rien d'étonnant d'affaires cahuzac à la
ferveur quelques dizaines de mois
seulement séparent le présent projet de
loi de la loi organique du 14 avril 2011
d'ailleurs au elle aussi d'inspiration
élyséenne bénéfices secondaires en 2011
donner l'impression de rattraper un
retard supposé sur nos voisins dans la
défense de l'ordre moral
en rebaptisant conflit d'intérêt ce qui
ressemblait trop
à un point relisant trafic d'influencé
bénéfices secondaires aujourd'hui
renforcer un peu plus le contrôle
judiciaire bureaucratique et d'opinion
sur les élus nationaux et locaux
et pourtant et pourtant dans la
chronique des scandales politiques de
ces trente dernières années
on peine à trouver la trace de
parlementaires en tout cas en tant que
parlementaire on y trouve
essentiellement des membres de
l'exécutif ou des personnes liées à
l'exécutif par toute la gamme des liens
de la connivence de classe inconsciente
au calcul froid en passant par les liens
familiaux de camaraderie et d'amitié
tout simplement parce que nos systèmes
concentrant l'essentiel du pouvoir
politique à l'elysée et dans ses
satellites les nécessités de sa conquête
et de sa perpétuation rendent plus
regardant sur les moyens tout simplement
parce que c'est là que tout ce qui
compte se décident choix généraux comme
décision de porter individuelle et
pratique
c'est pas au parlement comment empêcher
alors lorsque tout se joue là qu'il en
aille différemment
comment éviter que l'élection
présidentielle perçue de moins en moins
comme un acte politique est de plus en
plus comme une cérémonie magique de
conjuration et de résurrection ne
débouche sur la désillusion et la
rancoeur réduction de la fracture
sociale
travailler plus pour gagner plus le
changement c'est maintenant même si
elles jouent leur rôle
l'élection présidentielle même si elles
jouent leur rôle dans l'élection
présidentielle celle ci ne fait se fait
pas sur des promesses précises mais sur
l'espoir qu'on a réussi à faire naître
et le changement c'est maintenant s'est
produit les lecteurs le changement pour
moi pas la xxi ème réformes
structurelles de ceci ou de cela pas la
réforme pour rassurer bruxelles berlin
le 4 40 ou les marchés que sais-je la
désillusion n'est du décalage de plus en
plus grand entre politique et la
communication qui en tient lieu le
problème de la vème république finances
philippe finissante pardon mais pas le
parlement mais l'exécutif c'est
l'absence de contre-pouvoir politique
réelle qui explique les dérives dont se
nourrit le désaveu populaire
c'est pourtant le pouvoir législatif
qu'on entend à faiblir dans sa dans son
intervention tout à l'heure alain
anziani a rappelé l' affaire du médiator
mais la sphère du médiator précisément
elle s'est réglé rapidement et sans qu'
on est à changer la loi au parlement
regardez regardons les choses de près
même les cavalier masqué du petit matin
ne peuvent aboutir sans l'intervention
ou le consentement de l'exécutif un
exemple récent qu'il que nous rappelle
la faire la faire tapis au courant
c'était en février 2007 donc en cours
delà de la campagne d président et
dernière présidée avant dernière
présidentielle
on discutait d'un texte sur la réforme
des tutelles et puis tout d'un coup un
amendement qui vient élargir le champ
d'utilisation de la de la tractation
dans le pardon de la procédure
d'arbitrage dans qu'il aille qu'il
élargit donc encore plus et qui sécurise
est bien évidemment cette procédure dont
on a vu tous les attendus
appelez après le bon sens et l'honnêteté
donc voudrait qu avant de désigner dans
l'urgence les responsables de la vague
les responsables de la vindicte publique
et de bricoler en hâte des remèdes
législatif destiné à faire tomber la
fièvre on prenne le temps du diagnostic
le temps de l'inventaire des moyens de
traitement déjà disponibles et de leurs
marges d'amélioration car il y en a le
bon sens et l'honnêteté intellectuelle
voudrait que l'on s'interroge sur la
nature du processus de décision
démocratique sur ce que signifie intérêt
général
plutôt que de se contenter de salm odier
que ce n'est pas la somme des intérêts
particuliers
cet hymne avance guère vous le vous le
pensez bien évidemment le bon sens c'est
l'honnêteté voudrait corrélativement que
l'on définisse en quoi consiste le
conflit d'intérêt pour un parlementaire
les limites de la notion ses rapports
avec les manquements au devoir de
probité du code pénal comme prise
illégale d'intérêt comme favoritisme
comme trafic d'influencé
les conditions dans lesquelles ces
propositions de loi ont peut être exempt
né par notre commission des lois je
n'insiste pas tout le monde le sait
mériterait à elle seule un retour en
commission est d'autant plus que celui
celle ci cela a été rappelé plusieurs
fois qu' il y a deux ans à peine elle a
quand même produit un rapport
suffisamment fouiller pour que l'on
parte de là pour réfléchir d'autant plus
que le rapporteur on a retenu surtout
les propositions allant dans le sens
répressif en évitant soigneusement d'en
épouser la logique et l'essentiel qui
était de refuser la publicité des
déclarations contrairement à ce qui nous
est proposé aujourd'hui la commission
des lois nous propose même de revenir
sur le léger la dernière réduction que
l'assemblée nationale a introduites
ainsi intérêts matériels et intérêts
moraux décision particulière et
décisions de portée générale activité
professionnelle mandat électif et
associatif se trouve-t-il mêlée dans le
même grand sac d intérêt potentiellement
en conflit c'est de ce grand sac est
censé sortir le génie et la lumière et
ainsi que la morale le plan de travail
de la commission des lois
si vous accepté ma proposition il est
très simple adresser d'abord le
diagnostic la vie politique française
est elle si réellement corrompu qu'elle
nécessite la présence la présence
d'hormones ans de coin de table
je me contenterai ici de remarquer que
quand nous l'avons interrogé le
président de la commission pour la
transparence lui même nous a dit qu'en
25 ans d'examen de 25000 dossier et bien
il y a eu seulement quatorze personnes
concernées dont six parlementaires qui
ont été transmises aussi transmis au
parquet qui n'a pas donné suite
l'enrichissement inexpliquée ne
constituant pas un délit alors s'il faut
à n'en pas douter donner plus de moyens
d'investigation à la commission on
définir les moyens juridiques qui
permettraient de mieux sanctionner
l'enrichissement illégal vient la mise
sous surveillance générale et
pratiquement tous les acteurs publics ne
me semble pas le métal la méthode
le remède adapté la france nous dit on
serait au 24e rang des pays les moins
corrompus selon un indice de
présomptions de corruption de
transparancy international classement
certes peu glorieux mais outre que la
scientificité de la notion de plutôt
corrompus ne saute pas vraiment aux yeux
il est troublant de constater quand on
regarde le classement 2011 que parmi les
pays mieux notée que nous se retrouve 13
paradis fiscaux dont 10 dont les dix
meilleurs du monde selon le magazine
forbes
autres éléments du diagnostic
l'inventaire de l'arsenal répressif très
répressif existants l'évaluation de son
efficacité par rapport à celui des
autres pays démocratiques
s'agissant de la répression des
atteintes à la probité des acteurs
publics en tout cas notre code pédales
et la jurisprudence sont
particulièrement répressif la définition
de la prise illégale d'intérêts par le
code pénal est tellement large que les
actes les plus légitimes comme pour un
élu de voter une subvention pour un
organisme dans lequel il représente sa
collectivité s qualité hors de tout
enrichissement personnel peuvent être
qualifiés de prise illégale d'intérêt la
cour de cassation ne fait pas de
différence entre intérêt moral et
financier intérêt général et intérêt
personnel
même constat pour le délit de
favoritisme qui est constitué même en
l'absence d'intention d'avantagé
quelqu'un dès lors que la procédure de
passation des marchés n'a pas été
strictement réservé respecté par deux
fois
le sénat a adopté à l'unanimité une
modification de la notion de prise
illégale d'intérêt et une fois celle de
favoritisme par crainte des réactions
médiatiques
ces textes ont jamais été inscrit à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
je constate que notre rapporteur s'est
abstenu de reprendre cette nouvelle
définition de la prise illégale
d'intérêts c'était pourtant une des
préconisations du rapport que nous avons
évoquées n'apparaît nulle part non plus
cette conclusion du rapport je cite
l'étude des régimes de prévention des
conflits d'intérêts et de leur
application concrète dans les parlements
occidentaux révèle que le système
français est globalement plus performant
que celui de nombreux états
deuxième type de questions ensemble de
questions celle de la question de la
décision
qu'est ce que c'est qu'il dit la
décision comment ça se passe dans une
assemblée démocratique non seulement le
présent projet de loi qu'on
fonds décisions individuelles pratique
qui est le fait des exécutifs et
décisions de portée générale définition
de règles applicables à tout le monde
mais il renvoie à une conception
totalement erronée à mon sens de la
prise de décision collective au sein
d'assemblées démocratique conception
erronée à mon sens parce que la décision
conforme à l'intérêt général comme on
voudrait nous le faire croire mais pas
le produit d'atomes civique purgé de
tout précisé
comme les eaux usées de nos stations
devraient être purifiée et bien à nous
la part le regard purificateur de
l'opinion si c'était le cas
donc c'est pas ça la décision
démocratique
si c'était le cas ne pourrait participer
comme ça a été remarquée à la décision
seulement ceux qui tiennent leurs
connaissances de la lecture des journaux
de leurs consignes de vote et pas du
tout de leur de leur pratique tous les
autres devraient donc s'abstenir idée
perverse car la décision démocratique
est le produit d'un débat public régler
au sein d'une assemblée représentative
dans l'idéal de tous les intérêts et
opinions
ce qui suppose des parlementaires
d'origines diverses
des parlementaires présents et actifs
soigneusement questions soigneusement
évité ce qui suppose que le débat ne
puisse être biaisé et qui pose la
question de la désignation des
présidents de commissions et des
rapporteurs
le groupe de travail autre conclusion
qui a été passé à la trappe avait
d'ailleurs conclu que c'est à ce niveau
que le risque de conflit d'intérêts
existe vraiment au parlement non pas que
les gens des riber et qui ont un intérêt
délibère mais que la manière de poser le
débat soit biaisée par celui qui doit le
petit bleu présente qui le présente et
qui le mène troisième ensemble de
questions celles que la commission devra
se pose est celle de l'efficacité des
dispositifs de prévention aux
manquements au devoir de probité
publique tel qu'il est proposé dans
cette proposition de loi pour répondre
au désenchantement public
suffira-t-il
chers collègues que vêtus de probité
candide leur déclaration de patrimoine
sur facebook danse et c'est dans une
main et celle d'activités d'intérêt sur
twitter les élus du peuple
les partenaires les parlementaires les
élus locaux acceptent stoïquement leur
vole leur rôle de bouc émissaire au
motif que personne n'est obligé d'être
candidat je pense que non d'abord comme
on l'a vu parce que l'origine de la
crise de confiance des citoyens dans
leurs institutions et les acteurs
publics n'est pas ce n'est pas l'origine
ce qu'on prétend
ensuite parce que l'euromed ne fera qu
aggraver le mal la publication des
déclarations non seulement n'empêchera
pas les trafiquants de trafic et on
découvrira seulement à l'occasion d'un
scandale il avait menti mais fournira un
aliment permanent au harcèlement de ce
qui ne leur ont pas fait non seulement
la défiance publique continuera à
s'alimenter des scandales qui
continueront comme ils ont continué
après chaque train de mesures de
diversion mais elle trouvera un aliment
nouveau dans la contemplation des
déclarations les commentaires qui ont
suivi la publication du patrimoine des
membres du gouvernement
encombrée de vélo de voitures venant du
contrôle technique d'estimation
immobilière sont édifiantes
quant au patrimoine de pierre moscovici
commente le journal de référence du 17
mars du 17 avril 2013
à seulement des 170 mille euros il est
presque aussi maigre que la croissance
du pib français
rien n'est dit
tout est dit la recherche de la
transparence pourrait bien être le
meilleur moyen de perpétuer l'obscurité
sur les processus de décision qui
importe vraiment selon le principe
pascalien qui veut faire l'ange fait la
bête
l'objectif de cette proposition de
retour en commission vise simplement mes
chers collègues en nous invitant à ne
point trop faire l'ange à nous permettre
de moins sur la bête
merci je vais passer la parole à
monsieur jean pierre michel orateurs
contre la motion merci monsieur le
président monsieur nuit de tirs
collègues à cette heure tardive
je ne vais pas me lancer je ne vais pas
me lancer dans des excès littéraire de
monsieur collombat les affaires nous en
connaissons tous et je dirait qu'ici
nous avons tous notre croix et que je ne
pense pas monsieur lézard tout monsieur
tapie étaient des membres du parti
socialiste ont bien entendu ici un
certain nombre de propos excessifs
excessif car lorsqu'on parle à cette
tribune où ici on parle pas seulement
pour soi on parle au nom de son groupe
au nom de son parti politique et
éventuellement des ministres de son
parti qui font partie du gouvernement et
qui doit forcément partagé les propos
que l'on tient à cette tribune
alors monsieur collomb bas messieurs
colombes à nos concitoyens nos
concitoyens attendent des textes ils
attendent des mesures et les réflexions
que vous demander à la commission des
lois defferre
si jamais ce texte lui renvoyer ces
réflexions ont été faites
elle nous a été faite par le
gouvernement elles sont d'ailleurs dans
l'exposé des motifs
et c'est à partir de ces réflexions que
on nous propose un certain nombre de
textes d'articles que d'ailleurs et
l'assemblée et nous mêmes avons modifié
sur le patrimoine
je passe sur tous les conflits
d'intérêts faut-il parler mes chers
collègues ici au sénat les conflits
d'intérêts faut-il s'en tenir à la
déontologie du bureau de notre sénat
faut-il dire le nom des parlementaires
ici qui acceptent des voyages à
l'étranger en dehors de tout cadre
sénatoriales invité par des puissances
étrangères
pour y faire quoi
alors il suffit de déclarer à qui est ce
que ces déclarations sont publiques
est ce qu'on sait ce qui en résulte non
nous avons besoin de texte la
déontologie est d'ailleurs ne suffit pas
on le sait très bien et dans les autres
professions
c'est pareil c'est pareil on sait très
bien que les sanctions disciplinaires
infligées par les ordres sont totalement
insuffisants et que la justice doit
participer
lorsqu'il le faut donc cette loi est
nécessaire
le commission des lois a travaillé elle
a travaillé d'abord sur la base de
fameux rapport y est et c'est que
l'autre rapporteur a pris en compte
qu'il a répétée tout au long des
amendements pour accepter certains
amendements notamment de monsieur est
notamment de monsieur collomb bas mais
sûr que l'on bat d'ailleurs qui étaient
présents ce matin et non pas la semaine
dernière je crois mais ce matin qui
avait pris la parole très souvent très
souvent et qui avait et qu'ils avaient
et qui avait eu quelques succès dans vos
amendements pas dans tous quelques
succès dans vos amendements
donc franchement franchement
alors bien sûr qu'il ait jamais urgent
de ne rien faire parce qu'on n'a rien à
se reprocher lorsque tout va très bien
dans le meilleur des mondes
lorsque le monde politique et nous mêmes
nous sommes portés aux nues par nos
concitoyens
lorsque nous sommes pas suspecter parce
que nous ne sont pas la femme de césar
il faut rien faire c'est ce que vous
proposez est ce que vous proposez et
bien moi je pense tout le contraire je
pense qu'il faut agir et que le
gouvernement et le président de la
république ont été bien intentionnés
d'agir rapidement
après une affaire scandaleuse qui est l
affaire cahuzac et que nous portons et
que nous portons nous comme une croix
oui mais à d'autres antérieures donc là
dessus soyons clairs et nous nous
faisons pas porter la faute sur les uns
ou sur les autres
nous devons légiférer nous devons agir
et rapidement c'est la question pour
laquelle au nom de mon groupe je
m'oppose à cette motion de renvoi en
commission
merci monsieur michel je vais demander
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
président en sueur vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre tout a été dit et bien dit par
monsieur michel je voulais faire
observer à monsieur collombat que s'il
avait voulu que l'on prenne en compte la
définition du conflit d'intérêts à
laquelle il a fallu ions et une était
tout à fait possible de déposer un
amendement à ce sujet d'ailleurs ils ne
manquent pas il ne manque pas de déposer
d'amendé amendement est d'ailleurs eu 10
de travail et de concourir beaucoup un
autre à vos mes chers collègues
la commission des lois a déjà consacré
12 heures à l'examen de ce texte 12
heures 12 heures mais mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas fini puisque je
dois dire que ceux qui voudraient je dis
à ceux qui qui voudraient soutenir cette
motion à laquelle je suis opposé qu'il
ya une pièce de beaumarchais qui
s'appelle la précaution inutile comme la
commission des lois est d'ores et déjà
invités à se réunir dès la fin de la
présente séance
de toute façon car il reste encore
quelques 200 amendements à examiner
de toute façon la commission des lois se
réunira et ceux qui veulent qu'elle se
réunisse sont d'ores et déjà se
satisfait mes chers collègues nous
sommes extrêmement heureux de nous
retrouver en commission l'atmosphère est
excellente on a des débats approfondis
et on ne ménage pas notre temps ni notre
pain surtout en ce mois de juillet est
aussi durant le mois de juin et le mois
de mai le mois d'avril
donc c'est un plaisir sans cesse
renouvelé de toute façon c'est prévu
mais si vous voulez que en plus il ya
une motion et bien vous pouvez la voter
mais je pense que c'est vraiment inutile
mes chers collègues
merci
à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président je pense
que en l'état de la situation
s'agissant d'une procédure parlementaire
s'est passé ici gouvernement s'exprime
d'habitude mais j'ai pour ligne de
conduite de ne pas donner d'avis puisque
c'est une règle propre au parlement et
que sur le renvoi en commission
naturellement ça ne concerne que
l'assemblée a qui disent oui merci
monsieur le ministre je rappelle
qu'aucune explication de vote n'est
admise je vais consulter le sénat sur la
motion de renvoi en commission déposée
par monsieur pierre yves collombat et
plusieurs de ses collègues
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe
rds sur cette motion je vous rappelle
que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable que le gouvernement n'a pas
donné d'avis il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées à l'article 56 de notre règlement
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 197 sur la
motion tendant au renvoi en commission
du projet de loi organique relatif à la
transparence de la loi de la vie
publique nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 346 pour l'adoption
188 contre 158
le sénat a adopté la motion de renvoi en
commission
et pendant cette suspension de séance la
commission des lois s'est donc réunie et
là coup de théâtre elle a rejeté à son
tour le projet de loi organique
la séance a été reprise aux environs de
22h 15 pour annoncer le report du projet
de loi sur la transparence de la vie
publique je vous propose donc tout de
suite de revoir cette séance la séance
s'est reprise 20 la parole est à
monsieur le président soeur pour nous
présenter les conclusions de la
commission des lois
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à la suite
de l'adoption par le sénat de la motion
de renvoi en commission présentée par
monsieur pierre-yves collombat que je
salue la commission e à l'issue de sa
réunion a fort logiquement constat n'est
de constater une majorité homothétique
avec la majorité qui adopté le renvoi en
commission dans l'hémicycle donc on voit
là une logique
je ne dis pas que tout est logique mais
là il ya une logique qui est
incontestable
donc la commission à l'issue de sa
réunion a décidé de rejeter le texte du
projet de loi organique relatif à la
transparence la vie publique qu'elle
avait adoptée pourtant lors de sa
réunion du mercredi 3 juillet 2013
mais la commission a le droit d'évoluer
dans ses pensées et dans ses
appréciations madame létard
la commission a informé ses membres et
ce fut l'office de notre collègue
monsieur jean-pierre michel qui la
préside et qu'en conséquence et en
application du premier alinéa de
l'article 42 de la constitution la
discussion porterait en séance sur le
texte du projet de loi organique tel
qu'il a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture
merci monsieur le président il résulte
de ce rapport que la commission ayant
rejeté le texte qu'elle avait adopté le
sénat doit examiner le texte du projet
de loi organique tel qu'il nous a été
transmis par l'assemblée nationale le
sénat changeant de base de discussion le
droit d'amendement doit désormais
s'exercer sur le texte de l'assemblée
nationale nous pourrions fixer un
nouveau délai limite demain mercredi à
13h pour le dépôt des amendements
la séance sera ouverte à 16 heures afin
de permettre à la commission des lois de
se réunir au préalable pour examiner les
amendements
madame swing le vous avez la parole oui
monsieur le président monsieur nice mes
chers collègues il me semble qu il y a
un problème au niveau du règlement je te
rappel du règlement vertu de l'article
47 terre qui fixe les délais limite pour
le dépôt des amendements
par la conférence des présidents or
aucune conférence des présidents ne
s'est réunie monsieur le président et je
ne trouve aucun article qui permet de
délimiter ainsi un délai sans passer par
la conférence des présidents par
ailleurs fixé un délai aussi court à
demain il est totalement impossible de
redéposer de nouveaux amendements
puisqu'il s'agit pour nous de reprendre
un texte complètement de fond en comble
un texte qui est totalement que que nous
rejetons totalement aujourd'hui il est
impossible dans un délai aussi court de
travailler dans des conditions sereines
monsieur le président donc je vous
demanderai que à ce que ce soit une
conférence des présidents qui fixe un
nouveau délai qu'on puisse en débattre
en conférence des présidents
la parole de monsieur pierre yves
collombat pour que la démarche est un
sens il faut qu'on reprenne le texte
qu'on fasse comme je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure en commission un peu le même
type d'exercice qui a été fait sur le
texte sur la décentralisation on était
arrivé à un texte que j'ai voté parce
que je trouverai qui correspondait bien
à nos à nos attentes qui étaient assez
différent du texte initial bon si pour
n'étant absolument incompétent en
matière de procédure mais je vous dire
si c'est ça c'est une pantalonnade
donc je pense que vous pourrez passer le
texte monf a vraiment ça n'a strictement
aucun sens donc au minimum je pense que
ce que dit 22 l'est du beau et de bon
sens
au moins que la conférence des
présidents essaye de voir s'il ya moyen
parce que j'ai regardé l'emploi du temps
quand même prévu sur le ska la fin du
mois je sais pas
il n'y a pas des textes d'une urgence
extrême et ses alliés à ces deux il ya
assez de vide pour pouvoir continuer à
travailler il faut au moins qu'on ait
quelques heures plus que quelques heures
pour essayer de voir si on peut trouver
au menu ce operandi et quelques
principes sur lesquels on pourrait on
pourrait être d'accord autrement tout ça
c'est de la procédure et ça confirme
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai dit je le pouvoir
il est à l'elysée on est là pour valider
ce que veut l'elysée bon bon je veux
bien mais c'est pas sa fin on creuse
notre temps aux mains en tant
qu'institution bon on n'y ait personne
n'y est pour rien mais je constate que
d'année en année c'est pire
ça tient pas aux hommes ça vient pas aux
gens ça tient à la dérive de nos
institutions mais oui mais oui chers
collègues ça se passe comme ça veut dire
c'est à peu près ce que vous avez dit
que donne une autre d'une autre façon je
dire qu'il n'ya plus de contre-pouvoirs
bon très bien et si ça c'est pas pour
bien sûr les hommes sont les hommes et
ils essayent de tirer la couverture très
bien mais c'est pas ça le fond du débat
donc si nous mêmes nous n'arrivons pas à
essayer quand même de faire quelque
chose qui ressemble à quelque chose
enfin c'est la débandade totale hors
bons va peut-être que la procédure vous
permettra de faire passer ce que voulait
faire passer enfin ça serait lamentable
merci chers collègues la part est
évidemment celle ci oui je j'ai très
rapide pour dire simplement que mon
groupe et moi même regrettons la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
retrouvons ce soir j'ai le souvenir de
d'autres situations où le gouvernement
avait su user de procédure qui nous
avait contraints chlore nos débats dans
une pré tipi précipitations que je
regrette encore aujourd'hui je regrette
d'autant plus cette situation qui me
semble que les ans les grands oubliés
ce sont les français et ce que j'ai pu
dire tout à l'heure dans mon
intervention général à savoir la façon
dont ils ressentent le décalage entre
eux et les élus aujourd'hui je crois que
ce soir nous
bien évidemment ils ne sont pas des
millions à nous regarder mais dans le
même temps les choses se savent et que
nous ne renvoyons pas une bonne image du
parlement et particulièrement du sénat
donc moi je ne suis pas une procédure
hier je ne sais pas quels sont les les
outils justement procédurier pour que
nous puissions enfin débattre de ce
texte qui pour moi est important la
transparence a du sens pour moi et je
crois que sincèrement nous appelons
cette transparence
quel que soit le lieu où nous nous
situons aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle
donc il faut que nous puissions discuter
de ce texte en toute sérénité monsieur
croc en bas je vous entends bien mais il
ya eu des votes des votes ont du sens
ou alors ça ne sert à rien de voter
donc ça ne sert à rien d'ouvrir départ
appuyé par vous même trop de jeu par là
monsieur coulombe a pas donc pas la
peine d'ouvrir des parapluies la chose
est faite nous savons qu'ils qui a créé
les conditions de là où nous en sommes
ce soir il faut l'assumer
si c'était mon cas où le calme en groupe
nous savons l'assumé mais je ne trouve
pas très élégant de votre part que de
renvoyer cette situation a d'autres à
d'autres ce soir voilà donc moi je ne
sais pas quelle peut être l'issue de
de la situation en tout cas je réaffirme
que pour mon groupe est pour moi même il
est nécessaire que nous ayons une
discussion approfondie sereine qui
prennent de la hauteur
justement sur un sujet qui peut être
mais pas la préoccupation première de
nos concitoyens parce que je dois vous
dire une chose c'est que peut-être que
plus que de la transparence
ce que regrette aujourd'hui les gens
c'est l'impuissance des politiques à
répondre à leurs besoins
c'est ça la question mais la
transparence selon moi en fait partie
donc trouver les trouverons les
solutions pour pouvoir discuter de ces
textes en pleine sérénité avec tout le
respect la responsabilité et les
responsabilités je voudrais dire qui
nous incombe
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole pardon merci monsieur ministre a
dit jean le gouvernement monsieur me dit
j'ai encore des demandes de parole ce
que vous souhaitez intervenir après où
c'est comme vous le entendue la parole à
monsieur zocchetto merci monsieur le
président dans les circonstances que
nous connaissons nous sommes surpris
qu'aucune réunion de la conférence des
présidents ne soit organisée nous les
uns et les autres nous avons un peu le
sentiment d'être sans gouvernance comme
les français d'ailleurs quelque part et
moi je suis d'autant plus surpris que ce
qui se passe actuellement était
prévisible
il suffisait de voir l'accumulation des
travaux de la commission des lois la
désorganisation totale où il en effet
que nous connaissons depuis un moment
donc il ya un moment évidemment ça
craque et ce soir bas
ça craque alors il faut trouver une
solution le sujet qui est que le
gouvernement souhaite aborder intéresse
le sénat nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas
attendu le gouvernement actuel pour nous
pencher sur ces questions
simplement nous pensons qu'une loi de
circonstance avec la procédure accélérée
ne peut pas prospérer
nous avons besoin de discuter
sereinement de cette question et
l'expérience que nous avons connu à la
commission des lois depuis quelques
jours ne permet pas de répondre à notre
souhait de discuter sereinement de
trouver un consensus
car nous sommes tous concernés et au
delà de nous tous ce sont les français
aussi qui sont concernés donc réunissons
la conférence des présidents
retrouvant un peu de sérénité et si on
veut voir comment on peut organiser
l'examen de ce texte avec une procédure
de dépôt d'amendements peut-être que le
gouvernement peut aussi retirer sa
demande de procédure accélérée
c'est vraiment il ya des domaines dans
lesquels la procédure accélérée s'impose
mais ces domaines doivent rester limitée
et là je crois que le gouvernement a
abusé et on voit les limites de
l'exercice
monsieur le ministre merci messieurs
président le gouvernement souhaite que
ce texte soit examiné sereinement mais
complètement et que la procédure soit
terminée
dans le cadre de la présente session
ordinaire qui comme vous le savez n'a
pas extraordinaire pardon comme vous
savez n'a pas là comme limite que le
décret donc si la conférence des
présidents
décide que il faut noter les c'est une
décision qu'on respectera si il est
décidé qu'on siègera à des dates plus
tard dans le mois de juillet au mois
d'août
le gouvernement sera à la disposition du
scénar pour que le débat aille jusqu'au
bout sur sept ce texte qui est important
dans le cadre de la procédure qui a été
choisi bien merci monsieur le ministre
j'ai plus de plaisir et oui elle est
chaque collègue excusez moi mais je ne
peux pas laisser dire ce que madame à
satiété
je prends mes responsabilités vous vous
avez pris la responsabilité s'agissant
de l'amnesty social pas avec les mêmes
conséquences bas avec quelles
conséquences
oh nous avons un certain nombre
d'opinions nous avons un certain nombre
de principes et nous nous battons pour
les faire respecter
point barre point barre comme vous comme
vous vous avez des comme vous vous avez
des principes
voilà c'est tout bon jeu si dans un
parlement on peut pas défendre
on ne peut pas défendre les valeurs
auxquelles on tient alors où est ce
qu'on va les défendre
nous ne sommes pas là pour exécuter ce
qu'on nous dit d'exécuter point barre
c'est tout voilà pour cette séance je
vous rappelle donc la principale
information de ce matin à le sénat a
donc décidé de reporté à l'examen du
projet de loi sur la transparence de la
vie publique la commission des lois doit
se réunir demain jeudi et le sénat
siégera vendredi et lundi pour examiner
ce texte qui était je vous le rappelle
une des réponses à la sphère cahuzac
bonne journée à tous
à